what would you say would be top three
issues to run for today like the other
day President Biden said the most uh
biggest enemy to America's white
supremacist which is very weird we're
going through all the stuff right now
you want me to be worried about white
supremacists okay fine maybe it's a top
50 issue it's definitely not a top five
or let alone number one issue that we
have
we know military industrial complex is
one Ukraine Russia totally get that what
else would you put as a top five issue
we should be paying attention to yeah I
mean this this issue we're talking about
certainly is at the top of the list uh I
think the second issue is
um is immigration and securing our
borders we cannot have a nation without
secure borders we are seeing the
consequences of President Biden's open
border policy that's impacting us uh in
in just about every way we see the
National Security threats of of having
an open border people literally
streaming across the border from all
around the world without any kind of
vetting or background that we don't know
who's in our country right now we don't
know what kind of threats they may be
posing there's obviously the economic
impact the social welfare system impact
there are so many layers uh of of
negative consequences that come from
their policy and the third would be
focusing on on bringing our economy back
focusing on on actually truly supporting
and investing in you know our small
businesses the the people that are often
touted as the number one Employers in
the country and yet have the hardest
time starting and staying uh in business
is actually focusing on what is in the
best interest of the American people
rather than uh what they are focusing on
which is themselves and their power
um to the detriment of the country I
think central to all of this just to
wrap it up
um in a foundational and fundamental way
is
truly supporting and defending our
freedom and civil liberties because we
are seeing that erosion in so many
different ways uh without our freedom
without our civil liberties we lose we
really lose what is at the heart of what
it means to be an American in this
country where would you put climate on
that list because I think at one point
you were a proponent of the green new
dude no I never was actually and got
some some crap from the Democratic party
for it I'm a strong environmentalist I I
have is why I ran for office in Hawaii
uh in the first place back in 2002 uh
protecting clean water preserving
natural resources preserving our Open
Spaces conservation of those
uh resources is essential uh you know
advocating for and promoting things like
regenerative Farming versus factory
farms like actually making sure that
this planet that we live on can stick
around and you know help us help us
survive is uh is incredibly important
unfortunately what we're seeing with
this this climate change movement is uh
something that really isn't even
addressing all of these things that are
essential for us to be able to exist uh
and survive what about the uh what part
of the inflation reduction act that was
the largest investment in climate change
that we've ever done did you think that
was a good move what are your thoughts
on that no no I I oppose that
legislation because it was had nothing
to do with inflation reduction first of
all so it was sold on a lie
um and so funny and uh marketing really
I think that's literally all it was and
they couldn't even stick with their own
story on it they kept on calling it
exactly that the greatest climb oh no
wait sorry sorry people care about
inflation let's just call it the
inflation reduction but there was a
component of it on whatever it was 200
billion dollars that was dedicated to
climate issues was that something you
were navigated to
I don't see how I I did not see how uh
what they were advocating for would
actually address these these basic
environmental concerns that are very
real uh in this country
I think a lot of people who are
advocating for for that for those things
uh if you look at um their own personal
personal life decisions there's a lot of
hypocrisy there too I think the reason
why Adam's asking that question is
because he's deeply concerned with the
humidity in Miami and he was hoping he
wanted to do something about it yeah so
but that's you know that's what it is
you know so out here so by the way tell
us I just want to mention on on the
climate change question
um what's the name of the author who
wrote Jurassic Park
famous author Michael Christ Michael
Crichton he wrote a book and I I can't
remember the title right now but he
wrote a book like 20 years ago uh
Fiction it's a novel uh but it was about
exactly what's happening today where
just like we have the
military-industrial complex he didn't
call it this but it was kind of like the
climate change industrial complex of
people manipulating information and
narratives and quote-unquote scientific
data in order to support their own
industry essentially and uh anyway it's
it's a fascinating book and the fate of
fear yes okay it's almost like the
climate change version of 1984 yeah
almost and it's just it was in I I just
I just read it uh I listened to a lot of
audiobooks while I worked out it really
is because you you know there's some you
know it's a novel uh so there's there's
some action there's some Thriller
Thriller stuff in there but when you
look at the heart of it uh it's just one
of those eye-opening and kind of
insightful things so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign